thank you very much for this uh very
kind introduction
um it's a pleasure to be here uh it's a
pleasure to be at the simons institute i
have the good luck to be on the
sabbatical and i couldn't wish for any
nicer place to spend at sabbatical then
at the simons institute i would like to
thank of course
dick carp and christos and alice there
and all the staff it's a
fantastic place to be and i was thinking
why it is
actually such a nice place to be at the
simons institute and
perhaps for all of those those that know
it it's perhaps not
you know really that surprising um it's
like
if you think about it look a little bit
of the structure right so in the
in the background there's like uh you
know german organization
right then you have greek and italian
wisdom
okay then you have british direction and
diplomacy
and finally you have american
supervision
and also money and so that seems to be
seems to be a very nice
combination and so that's working out
fantastic well so thank you very much
to everyone i very much enjoyed now um
what i will talk about is a very classic
setup the most classic setup
and how you know codes are used it's
really the basic point-to-point
communications problem
and so what we have is uh the setup that
shannon set up in 1948 and where we have
a source just think of
bits iid bits they're transmitted over a
channel and the channel is something
very simple it's just either
if maybe flips bits or most of the time
i just talk about something even simpler
i just erase this bit so it leaves the
bits that's called the erasure channel
and then we have a decoder at the other
end and of course
our aim is to transmit information
reliably and we have some criterion so
for example the number of bits
at the end at the decoder that we
estimate wrongly we want to be small
or perhaps the number of blocks and the
way of course to do this is
to use a code and the idea of the code
is to expand a little bit our
set of our bits make the you know
instead of taking one bit take a block
add a few bits to it that's called the
redundancy and
then transmit various blocks and then to
use these
blocks at the end and the extra
redundancy at the decoder
is so that even in the case you have
some problems in there that you can
still reliably
transmit and that you can do this and
that you can do this for every given
channel
up to a particular rate called the
capacity that's exactly
what shannon had promised and we know
exactly what the capacity is
but how we actually do this in a
computational efficient manner
that's really what i want to tell you a
little bit and i want to tell you a
little bit how
over the last you know since 1948 the
century years
you know some ideas how what people came
came up with
so this typically is called of course
the codeword and you know typically that
will be the block length and
those three parameters will play a role
now when we talk about coding in
in the setup of communications they're
really you know essentially what we
worry about is exactly this curve and
there you will see various versions of
such curves around and
parameters will be different but it will
always look a little bit similar
you will have some parameter that
describes the channel so
how many flips there are how much noise
is added for example in what's called an
additive
white gaussian noise channel where you
don't just flip bits but you add some
some noise to it or for example the
erasure probability so there will be
something
that characterizes how good or bad the
channel is and the axis sometimes you
know good will be on the left sometimes
on the right just historically because
the way things are parameterized are
different and then typically we
worry about the probability of error and
this might be either bit
or block probability of error it doesn't
really matter for our purpose
and then a code together with some
decoding algorithm
whatever we will consider will give you
some kind of curve
and tells you how over the various
parameters of the
of the channel how good and error
probably you get
and very often will just not deal with a
single button but we'll deal with a
whole family of such codes and typically
the family will be characterized by the
block length so that length will become
larger
and very much you know what we'll try to
see is how do these curves approach
hopefully this capacity limit the limit
that was promised by shannon okay
so how does the complexity grow can we
get there
what are the parameters that's really
what we are interested in in this setup
now if you go back a little bit so
here's just some you know history just
trying to squeeze things onto one slide
from 1948 some of the developments
and so what's nice about coding so i
hope you have you know maybe some of
these uh
words maybe i've heard maybe hamming bch
with middle
solomon ldbc clearly of course i don't
want to go through you know simply each
of these things
i'll just pick out a few ideas and try
to explain
um you know how they play in in the
overall story
what's nice about coding is that there's
a very close relationship
between what people have trying to come
up with the theoretical developments
and what people actually implement in
real systems
so typically you know if someone comes
up with something that's
a little bit better less let's say more
efficient uses less energy
uh within you know some years uh you you
know pretty much sure that this will
actually go into
into systems and originally the real
driving
motivation were maybe space exploration
uh probably also
military applications but then starting
around in the in the 60s
you know driving thing was already basic
communication
you know some of you probably still
remember uh some of the modems you know
that
that were used over telephone lines and
for example codex was one of the driving
company
uh they tried to exploit some of the
ideas that came up in the 60s exactly to
build
uh such modems and then of course later
on you've got fancy and fancy moderns
and these days of course we have encodes
in pretty much any
system whether it's storage or
communication you know or simply
basic communication of the internet
wireless etc etc
now if you look at this there are kind
of some groups in there and of course
the grouping is maybe also a little bit
uh artificial but what i want to do is i
want to very quickly just talk a few
words
about this algebraic setup then talk a
little bit about
lattices down here and then spend some
more time down here
on recent developments and i will be
fairly quick in the first two topics
simply because i i had to choose and
uh also just really i want to say a few
words just to to contrast it
on what's happening uh these days rather
than really getting into the detail
of what happened originally so let me
just say a few things
about the early days and so in the early
days
it was the ideas were really mostly
algebraic
and so the idea was that okay so we need
to
find a code the first thing is you need
to describe the code efficiently and so
the first thing you do is
rather than just picking code words
somehow that that might be
good for the purpose you want to give
some structure of the codewords and the
very
natural structure for the codes is a
vector space
so you're picking a vector space and so
all these codes that are up here are
what's called linear codes so these are
hamming codes return calls bch codes
and in particular what's interesting is
that hamming who worked you know more or
less next door to shannon when he came
up with it
and who originally introduced his codes
he was actually already not interested
in
coming up with a solution for the
communication system but his motivation
was actually the computing problem
these were the you know very early early
early days of computing machines hamming
was very
uh you know very prominent in this and
at that point i guess you had
relays that were fairly unreliable and
so he wanted to know
of how he could actually build more
reliable machines out of
uh not very reliable components and
that's how he came up with his hamming
codes
and so the basic idea independent of the
structure was that
if you think of now your block length in
this case it's trivial just three
you have your hammings cube in here
and you want to pick some points is that
you would like to pick
points in the space that are far apart
and you would like to also pick many
points because many points means high
rate
and far apart means that there are
somehow resilient against errors
but of course you cannot do the you know
clearly there's some tension
and so tension is you know these are
just two um
basic bounds that tell you that the more
you pick the higher the rate is
then the less the distance can be and
that's kind of some asymptotic bound
and these two bounds called the gilbert
martial power and the allies bound
they're not the best ones but their
reasonable bounds tell you
that you know you can pick a certain
number of points with certain distance
but it's not possible to pick many more
or to have larger distance right so this
was the basic idea
pick them in the space and you should
think of maybe perhaps a thousand
or some reasonable number like that and
so
why do we want to pick them far apart
that's also fairly clear because
if we have some perturbation let's
assume this one of these bits is flipped
then we'll end up at some other point
and this distance here this
distance d here that we choose the
points if we take
up to half of it then i can
actually still decode because i'll just
take it as a decoding
rule map it back to the closest point uh
that is a codeword okay so that was
the basic idea of how we should
construct code and this was called
bounded distance decoding
now where does algebra come in well the
algebra makes it kind of possible
to do this in a in an efficient manner
so let me first mention where these
codes were used
well as i said space exploration was one
of the early beneficiaries of it
and then perhaps one of the prominent
most prominent examples where read
solomon codes were used as course cds
which these days also look already a
little bit outdated but not that long
ago
pretty much ruled the world in digital
media content and of course anything to
do with storage
so where did you know algebra come in
well the algebra came in is to make
things efficiently describable
uh come up with codes that were at good
distance
and come up with algorithms that allowed
them to decode
efficiently right so this was the basic
idea find
do some packing in hamming space use
algebra
trying to come up with many points that
are far apart
and come up with a efficient algorithm
okay so that's all i really want to say
about
the algebraic notions in here and really
just to to contrast it and later on with
the ideas that i would like to set forth
now in the 70s you know things
changed a little bit and some new ideas
came in and
the um the basic uh point there was the
following that
uh on the one hand when i gave you this
notion before it was some abstract
channel right so you had
zeros and ones and then they got flipped
and so on but when you're actually using
applications
you're transmitting typically in real
space you're transmitting real signals
so these are not abstract zeros and ones
but
these are let's say sinusoids or you
know some other signals
and even if you abstract it into a real
space what you now have is
real numbers you're having zeros and
ones that you're transmitting or pluses
and minus ones
rather than the logical zeros and ones
so
once you know so how do you translate
well it's pretty obvious that you can
take for example if you just want to
transmit
two signals now this is a real axis here
imaging for example a voltage
along a line or maybe some other you
know real value signal
then you can just match the logical zero
and one perhaps to the plus minus one
but perhaps you need more of them and
then it's also fairly clear that you can
uh can take big sequences to label these
things
but if you think about what you're
really doing right then what you're
really doing is you're picking
points in some you know in some signal
space here
and so you can imagine that you know
think of let's say the standard
uh lattice cn that you can pick points
out of a set of points and these are now
your code words in actual real space
right so that's a slightly different
setting and so now you have the
equivalent that we had beforehand so the
equivalent problem now
is that how do you now but in real space
pack
points in real space and again you would
like these points
to be as far as part why because now in
real space the noise is typically
some gaussian noise that you add to it
and the further the points are part
the better typically things will be okay
so we have now the problem of how do we
pack
right and you know of course early on
already you know
for example kepler already considered of
how we could for example in three
dimensional space
pack spheres efficiently uh and so you
should think of these fears about
kind of a substitute for the distance
how far things are being or half the
distance
and the more spheres or oranges we can
pack
the happier we are okay so now one way
to do a packing
is to do in terms of a lattice and the
lattice is really the equivalent
of a linear code a linear code is
you take let's say in the binary field
you're taking rows here
of these old binary rows of length n and
the vector space
that's formed by these these are the set
of points so in this case for example
these two points
are formed by a vector space here and in
this case the dimension would just be
one they're just two points in here
okay and that this is exactly the same
but now in real space
now you're allowed to take vectors that
have real components
and now the equivalent of this linearity
here is that you're looking at the z
module so this means you're looking at
linear combinations of those the only
restrictions is that
the combinations that you pick have to
be integer combinations
and so now rather than getting points
here and having space you're getting now
points let's say in this trivial case in
in r2 and so all the points that lie on
this lattice so think of these two axes
that you have main axes as
as two of these rows in here and all the
points you get here would not be the
points on the letters
okay so now there's of course you know a
fairly
strong connection between these lattices
and the points i talked about beforehand
one way to construct the lattice and
it's called construction a
is that you simply start with a code and
again i can show you this only for a
trivial case so i start with a code
let's say that has four points in here
so this is the hamming cube
but now you think of this hamming cube
be embedded in real space
and you simply tile the whole space by
these hemming cues you shift them
and that's what you get and so now
that's a little bit difficult to see
so basically imagine these cubes and now
in each of these dimensions you have to
shift these cubes by two
okay now the only thing that i succeeded
is tile it by two dimension the third
one was just too complicated okay so you
have to imagine the third dimension
and so all the points that you now get
would be the blue points and so these
blue points perhaps that's the center
and you can see that essentially these
are now the dimensions of the letters or
these are the
the the vectors that span the letters
now if we actually do transmission
that's not the whole story
because when we do transmission we have
also
in real space a power constraint so we
cannot just
send any number of points that we want
right the points the codeword points are
those blue points here
but we have a power constraint we have
only finite power that we can spend to
send a signal
and so typically you can imagine that
this power constraint is that you simply
take the points
around let's say a center but only those
points that are within a certain sphere
for certain radius
and whatever the radius is is simply the
power constraint
that you have imposed on on your on your
device
now you can see that this becomes
already quite a little bit more
complicated
because even determining right so of
course in three dimension it's fairly
easy but imagine now
that you have a thousand dimensions and
that you have maybe two to that
thousand bits or two to the thousand
such symbols that you have or
such uh points that you have in the
lattice even just to know which points
are actually inside the sphere and which
ones are outside the sphere
if you have everything in dimension
thousand is already a non-trivial uh
problem to to determine and uh
so you know people have come up with all
kinds of ingenious ideas of how to even
address the points that would be inside
a region that should look
something like a sphere just to do the
decoding
not just to do the encoding okay so now
there's a nice connection between these
lattices and
and the codes many of the nicest
lattices that around like gauss's bars
uh leech lattices these are all kind of
rel related
to certain classical codes hamming codes
with miller codes scolar codes
by doing constructions like this
construction a but given that there's a
construction a you can also imagine that
there's of course a construction b and
the construction c and the construction
d
and the construction etc okay so there
are many many nice beautiful
relationships
and many of these lattices you can you
can actually construct in various ways
good so now there were two um you know
there were two nice developments that
happened in the
in the in the 70s that played actually a
fundamental role of how
uh these lattice was used in
communications in particular for the
modems
and the first one is something that's
actually you know fairly
clear once you see it mathematically
very simple
but it had a profound way of how these
models were constructed
and allowed to construct much much
better communication systems and that's
what's called underberg's set
partitioning scheme so let me just
explain in a second
what this scheme is so far you know we
had
simply a code and then we had the
lattice points there
but we didn't really make use of the
geometry of this space
so what ongerbeck realized is that you
can
do much better in the sense with much
less effort
achieve a very good performance if you
think of the geometry as well
so what is the basic idea let's assume
this is a two-dimensional
you know just two-dimensional space and
these are the points that i'm allowed to
use in two dimensions
and now you're using many of these
two-dimensional things to have a let's
say a thousand dimensional space right
and you're picking out
the points in here well some of these
points are quite close right
and so it's easy to confuse them but
some of these points are quite far apart
and it's very unlikely that you will
confuse them
so his basic idea was is to take this
and to partition it so for example
here's a particular partitioning
of this what's called 16 qam and every
time you partition the idea is that the
space you know the the the space between
inside the partition that the
diff the distance here it's now you're
cleaning this is larger
than the distance of let's say two
points that are uh
between the two partitions right and so
you go down further now you can see that
now the distance is again larger
etc etc right and so his basic idea was
that
if you now uh think of them and you
label this partition by
you know simply you went let's say to
the left it's a zero you went to left
it's a zero maybe then you go down here
uh it's a one that if you for example
here on the bottom
these points might already be so far
apart that there's no reason to have any
particular strong code in there okay and
so his idea was simply
to construct it much more carefully
rather than lumping everything together
put a very strong code on there and then
work very hard
to do the decoding let's just partition
it in this way and let's look at each
layer and try to figure out
what protection they actually need okay
and so it's a very simple idea
but it made it much much you know easier
why because for example on this label
you might not have to code at all so
there's no effort that's done
and also you know uh for example this
level you you know in the certain
partition you have to
you know have a very strong code but
since this is only one of several bits
in here even if this code is not
fantastic good it's not very close to
capacity
it's not that much that you lose because
you only lose on that particular level
okay so this was a very uh you know
a simple but profound idea that made it
possible to come up with
significantly better modems that uh
you know in the 80s you know i'm sure
many of you probably still remember
the modems that were used on telephone
lines and they were based
exactly on this scheme which is called
trellis coded
modulation the other basic idea is
again something very simple um and it's
but you know it's implementation
mathematica a little bit more
complicated
but you can explain it in you know in a
most basic version even even easier so
just imagine you have two dimensions
and so of course you should imagine
everything nine thousand dimension but
we just have two and let's assume these
are
the four points that we would be
transmitting well
there's something in what's called
wireless channel that's happening
and that's called fading fading simply
could mean in its simplest instance
that every dimension you have to think
of of one
possible point in time where you're
transmitting a certain signal
so it can happen that for example you
just walk around the corner
that just exactly at that point in time
when you're transmitting let's say this
dimension
your signal completely fades you get
nothing okay and so what this means
is that that these two points which were
first you know reasonably far apart in
space
suddenly completely collapse right so
that's clearly not very good
and again you know this is not in two
dimensions but you have to imagine that
in a thousand dimensions
and so um that's something called fading
and that you know clearly would be
catastrophic because there's no way
even if the noise is very very small
there's no way to tell if it was this
signal or this signal if you receive
something like this
right so the basic idea that you can use
is something that in two-dimensional
looks trivial
you know simply rotate okay so if you
rotate these signals in here
and you would again have a fade in let's
say this particular dimension
well these points would be closer
together but it would not be
catastrophic
okay you would still see actually
something you would still be able to
distinguish
and so now of course it's not quite as
simple as rotating in two dimensions
as i said think of it in a thousand or
ten thousand dimensions
uh think of it that the number of points
you have is two to the something a
thousand two thousand or whatever
but it's the same principle that you
have to apply
and so it's just some set of points uh
there's some very beautiful
constructions that come
that use algebraic number fields to
construct lattices that are
uh you know not prone to this type of
what's called fading
and have what's called a much better
diversity so
so these catastrophic kind of failures
that can happen they're much better at
tolerating them okay so now
this was um what i wanted to say
for the classical part the applications
again space
missions and in particular the modems
here
this was in 1984 was a big jump when
this
first time lattice were used was about
uh 9600 bits per second
uh okay so that doesn't sound a lot
these days when we have 50 megabits per
second but you know it's also
about 30 years ago and then the modem
the next mode in here
had about you know about 32 kilobits per
per second that's already uh not too bad
good
so what is the key idea here is that
first of all lattices are really the
equivalent of standard
linear code okay and if we use this
geometry
that we have in real space then we can
do much better so
one is this uh set partitioning by
ongerberg's
thing and the second one is that if we
want to combat fading
uh we can use some very nice uh number
theoretic schemes to come up with
lattices
that give us good schemes okay so now
let me get
um make a big jump forward and this big
jump forward is now to 1993
and in 1993 um something very um you
know exciting happened
uh namely two people that were actually
in circuit design
uh name peru and clavier and that
i don't think had done any coding
beforehand okay but had tried to
implement the code in
in an efficient circuit came up with a
completely different scheme which
now the many names they call it turbo
codes but by now it's a bigger area
called codes and graphs
low density pericheck codes uh you know
many other names for the same one
and this caused you know quite a big
uproar so this was the paper that they
had published in a conference in um
in geneva in 1993 and
what happened at around the same time is
that you know at the beginning people
didn't even believe that you know this
were really so good because these codes
were significantly better than
what anyone else had come up at that
point particularly for the complexity
they were
able to show but then what happened is
was some very interesting
uh you know there was something at this
time around in the air because
several other groups with different
backgrounds people statistical physics
computer scientists but also classical
qualifiers they all you know
over the next couple of years um often
completely unaware of what other people
had done came up with
ideas that were kind of similar and
related
and it took i would say roughly to the
year maybe 2000 or something like that
for people to realize uh you know that
essentially we're all talking about the
same thing
uh you know that they were all the same
principles and so let me tell you a
little bit
what this principle are and i will tell
you in terms of
these low density parachute codes and in
particular what people realized is that
what they had
discovered or what they had invented was
a version of something that gallagher
had you know already come up with in the
in the 1960s
that's not to take away at all from you
know what people did later
but it was something that had completely
been forgotten so what was the idea
the idea was that instead of you know
forget about minimum distance okay
anything i told you right now
forget it okay these chords have you
know are not based on trying to design
codes with good minimum distance
but these chords go the other way around
this code say what is a good algorithm i
might be able to use to do the decoding
and then ask what might be a good code
for this particular algorithm okay so
i'm not trying to design a good code
first
and then come up perhaps with an
algorithm that might be able to do it
but i do it the other way around
and so how do i come up with the
algorithm the algorithm
is simply taking one of the basic ideas
or representation of these codes
a little bit more literally and trying
based on this representation
to to use the representation itself as
an algorithm and what's this
representation
it's in terms of what we would these
days called a tenor graph and every
linear code has a representation like
this
it's a very simple representation it's a
bipartite graph in which these are the
bits so it's something very simple with
20 bits here and then these would be 10
checks and each of this check is a
linear parity check constraint so each
of this check is a constraint over
gf2 that says a certain number of these
bits here must sum up to zero that's it
okay every linear code is a
representation like this
now what was special about uh you know
gallagher's idea and the idea
that came later on what's special is
that you don't just take any linear code
but you take a linear code that's sparse
okay so what does sparse mean you take a
code that has very few edges
and so in in the representation here
what this would mean is that
i take every bit here in the simplest
case for example to have
degree three okay so every variable node
here participates let's say in three
checks
and perhaps every check here i would
take to check
six bits okay and so now what you should
think about is that these parameters
stay fixed
three and six stay fixed but the length
of the code
will go large okay so maybe perhaps a
thousand bits or 10 000 bits or 100 000
bits
so that the number of edges that i have
here is simply a constant times
n okay and so that's very different from
a standard code if i simply randomly
pick these checks
then i would get n squared edges and
that's very different okay so that's the
first
important thing now what are some other
parameters in here well i have so many
bits i have so many checks every check
takes degrad away one degree of freedom
so in terms of these parameters i can
basically tell you what the rate is and
the rate will be basically
one minus the degree of
the variable nodes divided by the degree
of the check nodes so in this case this
would be
a half okay good so that's the code and
now what's uh you know one other idea
that when you try to analyze it
is that you don't really look now at a
single a single quote but you look at an
ensemble you look at the whole family of
such code because it will make it much
easier to analyze
and so what does it mean well if any of
you have seen the configuration model
that's standard in for random graphs
it's exactly the same thing
you have these nodes these nodes have
degrees and they're edges
and so if we're deciding how to put the
edges the easiest way is to say if this
is a node of degree 3
make here 3 sockets and so on and so on
number all these sockets do the same
thing on the right hand side
the total number of sockets has to match
up and now simply pick a permutation at
random
and match things up and that's your code
okay and so if you do this
you will get a whole ensemble of such
codes every time you pick a random
permutation with uniform distribution
you might get a different code
and it turns out that if you think of
large enough codes all these codes
essentially behave the same
and so it's sufficient if we just figure
out what a random such code
behaves okay now
what's important is here that as i said
that what's really the key
is to think of the algorithm right so
this is a graph
this is a code that's well suited for
the following algorithm which is called
message passing
and it also goes by many different names
some of you might heard of
perl's belief propagation algorithm if
you go back to the physics literature
there's something called befree energy
which is
uh you know fairly related it's not an
algorithmic characterization but it's
essentially the same
the same concepts and there might be
other names for
exactly the same algorithm too so what
is the idea
well the idea is this is again our
graphical representation this telegraph
of the code
but now in addition we have these little
dongles here
and they tell you something about the
likelihoods that a certain bit
might you know let's assume you send a
zero what's the probability
given that i've sent a bit let's say
zero that i actually receive let's say a
one or did i receive a question mark
right so this
these extra dongles here tell you
the probability that certain bits are
what happens on the channel so they
characterize what the channel is
and so if you think now of the whole
model here
this whole graphical model is just a
graphical model that represents
the posterior distribution okay so what
do i mean with this
if you now see at this point here a
certain
you know outcomes let's say 0 1 1 0
whatever and so on
then this thing here just encodes the
posterior distribution that these bits
took on certain
values conditioned on what the output
was here okay so that's just a
compact representation of of the
posterior probability distribution
and what else is nice about this is
because everything is very sparse
we have only few edges in this whole in
this whole graph here and so there's a
factorization
where every factor only involves a small
number of variables that i have in here
and for such situations um you know a
message passing algorithm so a local
greedy algorithm
works actually quite well okay and in
particular the point is that
we are not you know we are not bound to
use any particular graph
but we are actually in control and we
can given the algorithm pick a graph
that works well under these con under
these situations okay so we have a lot
of degree of freedom
on designing this graph now uh you know
just in case you haven't uh you know
seen kind of
how this message passing on it works let
me just show it to you in the simplest
possible
setting that's called the binary erasure
setting so
this is a trivial graph which has only
three uh variables and two
uh and two checks here okay so this
represents an um
a code that has only two code words
okay and the codewords were the one
where these checks are both fulfilled
so let's assume now that that's what i
receive i receive zero
question mark and question mark and so i
don't know what these bits are and i
would like to decode
okay so the idea is that you're simply
sending messages back and forth and that
these messages are the best local
estimate you have about the bit
okay and you simply send it back and
forth and you hope that things
will converge and for the bc it's pretty
obvious what you should do you should
check for each of these check and try to
see greedily whether or not you can make
deductions right
for example this is a zero this is a
question mark but the mod two sum of
these two things right must be zero
so it's fairly obvious that this one
here must be a zero right because it's
the only
locally consistent uh consistent
configuration that i can make
so what you do is you're sending
messages back and forth you start with
the original received messages
you do some you try to come up with
local deductions so for example can i
locally greedily deduce what this is
based on these two values no i can't
because one is a zero one is a question
mark
this is an xor so i don't really know
what the value is
okay so i sent back a zero but for other
ones for example on top
as i said i do know what this is because
zero plus question mark must be equal to
zero so i actually know what the value
is
and i go back and forth send things back
and forth
and hopefully i can decode now
in 1997 um and i quoted the paper in in
the second
uh luby mitsuma uh uh chocolate
spiderman and simon
came up with a very nice uh um analysis
exactly of this case for the binary
ratio channel and the upshot is that
there's an extremely
compact representation of how such a
scheme works so the way you have to
think about it
you take such a graph that i described
to you degree let's say three on the
left
degree six on the right and you think of
a very large graph
and you think about under which
circumstances how bad can the
ratio probability be such that with high
probability it will converge to the
correct solution
and so the the final answer okay it's
very simple
and it goes as follows if this is the
erasure probability here
okay and so think of this is right now
is the as the
uh so this is the ratio probability of
the channel and this is the final
erasure probability after you're done
with decoding when you can no longer
make progress
then the performance the asymptotic
performance is is given by a curve that
looks like this
whose description is just this fixed
point characterization
okay so this is the the final erasure
probability think of and this is the
channel parameter
and these are the two degrees the right
degree and the left degree
and so you can see that there's an
explicit characterization
as epsilon as a function of the x way
you end up with and this curve is just
this this curve here okay it's an
extremely simple characterization
and so what turns out is that if you if
you're transmitting below this value
then with high priority you will be able
to decode
but if you're transmitting above the
value then with high probability will be
stuck somewhere at this point
and you have an explicit
characterization where you'll be stuck
with
okay so that's very nice very simple
characterization very clean
and so now the question is is this a
good code or not
well this is a plot for a 3 6 code as i
told you if 36 code has rated half
the capacity you know for that or the
worst erasure probability that you
should be able to tolerate is also half
well if you look at this it's not quite
a half it's about 43
that's not too bad okay it's a it's a
very low complexity algorithm but it's
not quite capacity capacity would be
here
so the other very nice idea that this
set of authors had in their paper
is that they said well we don't need to
pick this graph to be a regular graph
right
we can pick more complicated graphs in
particular we could just pick
let's say some of the nodes are degree 2
some are degree 3 some are degree 4
etc right and the analysis is carries
over you know
very simply with if you just take non
you know what's called irregular graphs
but they were able to actually come up
with a degree distribution
so a fraction of nodes that have the
various uh current
you know at various degrees and you know
the exact form
is is not really that important and if
you plug this one in
okay then you will see that you actually
can achieve capacity okay so you can get
arbitrarily close to the channel limit
with an algorithm
which is just this low complexity
algorithm
and you know you can construct beautiful
codes and actually once you understand
how this works
there's not just one but there are many
many ways of doing this
okay so this is for the binary ratio
channel what about more complicated
channels
well it turns out you can do the same
thing except it's a little bit more
complicated
in the general case you're not you're
not you know sending back and forth just
bits
or question marks you're actually
sending back and forth probabilities
and so to do the analysis a little bit
uh more complicated and there's no
explicit um characterization of the
of the of the threshold that you get
there's an implicit one in terms of a
fixed point characterization but if you
actually want to compute a value
you have to do compute numerically what
this value is but you can do this
um and so this is uh some years ago
he constructed now codes and degree
distributions that are good for this
and so what is this is now the gaussian
channel this is how much energy you
spend you want to be on the left
this is the capacity region according to
shannon
and you want to be as close as this and
so he came up with certain degree
distributions of
increasing degrees that get you know
very very close to this
now you know of course you know some
degrees for example this point here
which is extremely close is degree 8
000 and you can ask you know we have a
graph with 8 degrees 8 000
and the other thing that you can ask you
know how close is this really
well so in order to compare it you have
to check what happened before
you know turbo codes were invented where
worry well this is around
0.18 uh before the turbo thing we
weren't here
okay we weren't here okay we weren't
here we were actually outside of the
room
okay so this was about three on the
scale okay i would have to go for this
door
okay to show you the point so clearly
that was a big advance in
trying to come up uh with good codes and
so
even though you know you wouldn't really
operate here because these are
ridiculously large degrees
you can construct codes that get very
close and actually
achieve a good fraction of of that with
reasonable complexity
okay now you could do more you can
look at also the finite length
performance you cannot just
look at the infinite length one and you
can try to do some optimism optimization
so for example here this says try to
come up with code
whose curve air probability curve is
below this gray box here
and come up with the highest rate you
can do and so you can actually do that
and that was done in various contexts
either for lgbt codes or by people here
for example big carbon
and lubi in the context of what's called
weightless codes
and so you can also try to optimize
codes for finite lengths
good so where are these kind of codes
well since 1993 and you know essentially
they are
everywhere okay you cannot have any
device that doesn't contain it
that doesn't mean that all the other
codes are gone because uh you know for
legacy reasons typically devices have
all kinds of standards in there but
there's essentially no new standard that
doesn't use
these kind of either two of okay and
ldbc
r8 and many many versions but
essentially this idea okay so that's
really
the standard and the workhorse now in
pretty much
most communication modern communication
standards so what were the
key ideas forget about minimum distance
okay
simply come up start with an algorithm
this message passing algorithm
and then find a code or graph that works
well under this message passing and you
are in control of finding this graph
and if you find a good graph then you
know
this combination can work very well well
it has very low complexity and in
particular one of the things that have
not mentioned is that
for classical coding it's very hard to
take into account what's called soft
information what is soft information
well if i have only zeros and ones or a
question mark or not
that's kind of a hard information that's
just you know it's binary right
but if i have let's say a gaussian
channel then i not just get a received
value but i get also a value that tells
me
the reliability how certain am i about
that this value represents a zero and
one
and these codes are you know perfect for
also
uh you know taking that into account and
this software inflation can be very
important to get close to
uh capacity as i said uh in the illumi
dial one
uh you know there were explicit
constructions for capacity achieving
such
codes in the general case you can
characterize
uh by a fixed point equation what the
threshold is but at the end
and when you actually have to compute
the value there's some computation that
you have to do
okay now let me get to
the last two ideas
until you know recently information
theory which really says what the limits
are encoding theory
which tries to come close to these
limits which with uh with low complexity
schemes
they were a little bit like cousins but
cousins that were not really on speaking
terms okay
so you know yes they were closely
related okay
but they were a little bit awkward when
they got together right so if you
if you let's say taught a class in
information theory you would talk about
mutual information and capacity and all
the quantities here
and then you know if you also include a
little bit something about how you can
actually achieve these limits
then suddenly you talked about hamming
distance and other metrics
and there was no real direct connection
okay so
there was no capacity that suddenly
appeared in in the construction of codes
etc
right now fortunately this situation is
over
okay so we have now codes that have that
show a very beautiful
connection between them and they are due
to erdell arikan and they're called
polar codes
and if any of you you know teach a class
that's the perfect example that you
should use
their low complexity uh their capacity
achieving
they also have you know some problems
here and there but particular
for pedagogical reason there's nothing
that's better than that
okay so let's look at how they go um
okay
so um so we have let's say
uh two channels here okay and so we have
these two channels
and so these are two the same channels
let's assume the binary ratio channel
now let's append to these two uses of
the channel a small little linear
transform so these are two bits these
are two bits
that's just a matrix one zero one one a
very simple matrix okay
so we're just using these two together
and these we're thinking of our input
bits
now um let's think of this now in the
following way let's assume we first want
to recover u1
given the observation here but we have
no idea about what u2 is
okay so what are the set of equations
for this well if you look at this up
here u1 is x1 plus x2 u1 is x1 plus x2
that's just the
x xor in here right and both x1 we
receive an x2 we receive
so in other words what this means is
that u1 is just the xor
of let's think of for example the binary
symmetric channel it's just the xor of
the two received things that we have
okay so that's what the u1 will be and
that's what's just called a parity check
code
okay now let's assume that by some
miracle i was able to figure out what
the u1 is
and i'm looking at the u2 okay so u2
we have two sets of equations number one
u2 is equal to x2 that's this line here
and then x2 we receive okay so it's a
version of noisy version we receive here
but also we have the equation that uh
that we have u2 is x1 plus u1 u1 we
already know so it's just a constant
think of it as zero
so we have another version of the of the
u2 here right
so this is now something which is called
a repetition code we basically get twice
the same information in here okay now
nothing has really happened since this
transform is one on one
the overall capacity between here and
here is the same as the capacity between
here and here but let's now look at what
happens if this particular channels for
example have the bc then it's easy to
to check well if these two things are
erased with probably epsilon what's the
chance that this is erased well it's an
xor so it's erased if either of them is
erased which happens with one minus one
minus epsilon squared probability okay
so this is worse
right okay but what happens on the other
side well this is only erased if
both of them are raised okay and that
happens with probably the epsilon
squared which is better
right okay so now what is the total
capacity of if i'm thinking of these two
channels now separately
for the ratio channel capacity is 1
minus the ratio probably so the total
capacity is
one minus this expression which is just
the one minus epsilon squared
and on the this is one minus this which
is one minus epsilon squared if i
sort this out it's exactly two times the
original capacity that i have
okay now that it's just two times the
capacity is not surprising because
there was no capacity loss and this is
true in general
okay if i'm just thinking of a general
if i'm thinking of these two the mutual
information between input and output
that's exactly the same as the mutual
information between this and this
but that's just twice the mutual or the
capacity of the channel itself
okay so that's simply because i have a
one-to-one map and if i'm thinking of
now the splitting the successive
decoding that's just something
in case you've seen which is called
simply the chain rule of mutual
information okay so again
there's no loss on first thinking of one
channel and then
condition that i notice looking at the
other one okay these two type of
channels
cleanly separate there's no loss of
information involved in here
okay so um if i do this now if i can do
it once
okay so then i get two channels this is
better
this is worse this is better but if i
can do it once there's no reason i can't
don't do it twice
right and if i do it again and so now i
take two blocks like this
and i combine again like channels then i
get the 0.75
which becomes you know two of these
copies becomes even worse
and so some of them become even worse
some of them become very good
let me do it three times and you can
kind of see already why this will call
polarization codes because these numbers
will actually polarize to either zero
or one okay so that's really the miracle
of polar codes so let me just give you
another polar reset
another picture of this these are a
thousand channels to start with
they all have let's say originally a
ratio probably epsilon
i take always two pairs of them okay
some of them will be 0.75 some of them
will be zero and 20
25. i do this again i get four values
okay some of them will be very close to
one some very close to zero
okay i do this eight times you can kind
of see it already some move up some move
down
and so i do this now okay um and i do
this operation
ten times until i i've exactly
taken all these thousand channels
together and now you can see
a lot of them sitting on top these are
completely useless channels they see an
irrational probability of epsilon
versus a lot of them sit off the bottom
and these are
very good channels that see essentially
a ratio probably zero
and since i don't lose anything during
the you know i've shown that by doing
this there's no loss of information
the number of things that are good must
be exactly equal to
the capacity of the channel okay times
the length so
how do i use this now very simple idea
this is again my setup here i've said
that
some of these channels will be good or
bad so let's look at this
i do a successive decoder over this so
let me look at the top channel for
example
if you stare a little bit at it and you
look at what the
top channel depends on given the
received wells and given that you know
nothing about this
then this top channel just looks like
this it's just a
complete binary tree in which each of
this operation is just an
xor okay so this this top channel here
all it sees is the exo of the received
one so there's a very bad channel okay
if any of them is
is flipped or if any of them is erasure
you can't see anything
but each of this other one also is this
type of channel so example if you look
at the next one in the successive order
it's a slightly better channel because
it sees here repetition
and so if at least you know one of these
branches for example is received in the
binary erasure channel you will actually
receive the top
and so you can go through you can
characterize all these channels here
there will be a thousand channels here
this is the worst one this is all xor
this is the best one which sees a
repetition
and so what turns out that each of them
will be either a very good
or very bad channel okay and you have
exactly the right number of good
channels in here
so how do you do coding on them very
simple
you simply write them down think of this
as a thousand
let's assume red means very bad channel
blue means very good channel you have
the right number of good and bright
channels
okay and so um feel
okay good um not sure how we can get rid
of this
okay perfect so now how do you uh
how do you do this okay so you simply
freeze all these which are very bad
channels you declare them
to a fixed value let's say zero you go
down
in the decoding order from zero one two
three etc every time you see a channel
that's red
it's frozen you know the value and you
have declared the value both at the
receiver transmitter no problem
anytime you see actually a blue channel
it's a channel that's very good
and you can just decode it by this very
simple algorithm
which just takes n log n complexity
and is very easy to um to decode okay so
that's the idea
of polar codes polar codes very very
nice
you know prominence their provable
capacity achieving for white
array of channels people have uh you
know
uh people have come up with uh
extensions that go
you know once you see the basic
principle you cannot just use this for
channel recording and use this for
source coding for
multi you know for not just point to
point channels but pretty much any
channel you can think of
there's a version of this polarization
here and
now are there already applications not
really okay so this is 2008
you know perhaps in your 2000 you know
in your whatever
you know 2020 in your iphone 10 you have
it okay and then you should expect some
polarizing reviews
for these kind of uh um for these kind
of quotes but it's quite possible that
you will actually see them
uh in in applications i hope so
it's certainly true that if you want to
teach kind of coding
then within a few hours you can give a
scheme that gets you from
uh you know with some very basic uh uh
math can prove that you can achieve
capacity uh achieving schemes with low
complexity
uh the only thing that we're using is
the chain rule of mutual information
here
uh uh this here okay
and you need a little bit so this just
shows you that you don't lose anything
in the step
to show that you actually have
polarization there's a beautiful proof
by
emery teletub who just uses the fact
that if you can show that at
every single step you kind of increase
the variance of these numbers that you
get
then again it must follow that you get
polarization
and so with a little bit more work you
can prove how fast this polarization
happens
and it gives you some bound on the um on
the behavior of these codes
okay now let me get to the last idea
okay the last idea
is is physics okay now how does
uh how does how can you use physics to
come up with
better codes and now the type of chords
are called spatial coupling
okay and so how does that go okay now we
all know that
diamonds are forever okay except that
that's not true
okay because diamonds are not the most
stable form of carbon
uh and so it's just a matter of time
until
uh you know it's at least it's not the
most stable form of carbon in the you
know
under the current atmospheric pressures
that we experience i guess it was when
they were formed
and so it's just a matter of time that
this one will go actually in this
okay now even though of course it might
be that this is uh probably millions of
years and so you don't have to be
uh particularly worried but nevertheless
if you're trying to you know
contemplating buying one of these
okay it might actually be a safer bet to
buy one of these because eventually
that's exactly what you will get
okay now what why is that true well
um diamonds is a metastable form of
carbon so it's not the lowest energy
state that carbon can
can take on and so eventually it will go
to this
most stable state but it doesn't just do
spontaneously even though it's
metastable it needs something initially
to initiate this
this process and so metastability is
something that can be very useful
uh for example you all probably have
seen or perhaps many of you have used
heat packs right
so heat pack is another metastable form
of some liquid so this is sodium acetate
for example
and so this one can also have two forms
the metastable state which is the liquid
form in the stable state which is a
crystalline form
and so um how do you get from one to the
other one
there's a little you know a little metal
disk in here if you click on that disk
it will start the process which is
called nucleation it will form a small
nucleus
and once the nucleus is there you will
actually grow the crystal
and since the since the crystal form has
lower energy state
when you actually do this you will give
off heat right and that's exactly the
heat that you will see in the heat pack
and the nice thing about the heat pack
that's reversible you throw it back into
water
you put heat back it goes back into the
into the
metastable state and becomes a liquid
okay so what does this have to do with
coding well we can use exactly this
principle
uh also for coding now this
interpretation i give you now you know
i learned from physicists i'll um i'll
mention them a little bit later
the codes you know came before and but
then later on people realized that
that's exactly what's actually happening
so how do you do this we're back in our
realm of
ldbc codes that we had before and but
now what we do is we pick
several of those okay and so what you
should think of is that each of them is
already a reasonable sized one okay i
just draw something that has whatever
maybe 10 nodes
but you should think of each of them
already a code of a reasonable size and
now
you put them around let's say in a
circle okay so if you just do this this
itself is again a code but wouldn't be
particularly interesting okay this code
would just simply behave like 20
independent codes
but what happens now if you actually
start connecting them
if you start connecting them so how what
do i mean with this
well just for example there are many
ways of doing it for example take every
edge that you have in here
flip a coin let's say that has three
sides and then depending on how the coin
flip is you connect it to the left
you stay maybe in the middle or you
connect it to the right okay so what you
want at the end is something that looks
like a picket fence
where you're connecting neighboring
graphs but you want to do it in such a
way
that actually the the local graph
structure doesn't
stays the same so for example if
originally this was a three six code
where every variable node had degree
three every check note had degree 6 you
wanted it after that it's again if
locally a 36 code
okay we don't want to change this okay
so now if we do this this is completely
symmetric
okay and if you use that as a code which
is a perfect code again
okay what happens nothing happens okay
it behaves exactly
like this so in order for anything to
happen what we need to do is we need to
uh somehow get rid of this perfect
symmetry okay and so how do we do this
one way to do is
is to you can think of that you simply
cut the graph somewhere and how can you
cut
it one way to cut it is if you simply
set let's say bits at some
position here to a known value then if
these are known value then
essentially the edges are for nothing
okay if this is a known value of a bit
all it will ever send out is a known
value and you can forget about it's the
same thing as if you cut the graph
and once we cut it we can simply take
this
and we can you know put it out again to
something that looks at picket fence
it's just slightly nicer to see it now
in a local linear structure okay so what
will happen if you do this
now let's run again uh you know transmit
this is a code transmit it
again over your favorite channel and use
exactly the message passing algorithm
that i talked about before
right so what will happen well um
you know we have first a few parameters
we have the length of the coupling we
have the local coupling
with here and we have the we have the
local structure of the code that we have
in here
and so let me now show you how this
would behave if you run this
and so what do i show you show it for a
simple channel think of the binary ratio
channel
this is the channel parameter this is
the this is the threshold that we
originally got for the underlying graph
let's say the 36 code remember it was
about 43
and so now what i showed you here
there's like a hundred of these
instances each of these lines which you
can't see very well it's just one of
them
and i'm showing you the local erasure
probability as i'm
as i'm continuing to do the iteration
okay so what will happen is
you see that essentially let me run it
one more time
if you looked at this what happens in
the middle if you ignore the boundary
this would behave
each of them would behave essentially
exactly like the uncoupled system
okay so these points that you see here
in the middle would be exactly what you
would see for the same parameter
for a single system not very interesting
what's interesting is if you take the
same graph and now you go
above the what the what the uncoupled
system can do
and you go you know just below what the
system could do
if you did optimum decoding map decoding
was in general you know
quite complex you know to do would be in
general exponential complex to do
and now we run it again so what will
happen is very quickly
it will go down but then we'll get stuck
that's exactly the fixed point that i
had talked to you about
okay but because of the boundary at the
boundary we see locally more we have
more information there okay this was due
that we had fixed some bits there
what will happen is that actually this
is like a wave that moves in
and decoding can locally happen okay so
let me show you it once again
we'll we'll start the process this gets
stuck in the middle but at the boundary
it actually doesn't get stuck at the
boundary we can still do decoding every
iteration
think of it as a wave as a tsunami that
goes in at a constant speed into the
thing and can actually decode
okay and so this decoding works all the
way
up to the map threshold of the code so
up to the optimum processing that you
could do
even though this is a local and low
complexity algorithm
now of course if you go above there's
nothing you can do you will get stuck
and that's it okay show me let me show
you maybe one other thing it's the same
thing
as you do the parameter and go down with
the parameter
you would get stuck but as soon as you
go below the map threshold you will see
that this fixed point in which you get
stuck will evaporate
and you can slowly do the decoding until
you actually do optimum processing
okay good so um
maybe the final illustration of this um
if you go back to the physics
interpretation
if you take water and you put this water
in what's called a super
super cool state so you can freeze water
below zero but if the water is very
clean it will actually not freeze it
will
have it's again a metastable state that
can last a few hours
but as soon as you actually bump it and
you you initiate the process this
nucleation process
then actually the water will start
freezing and this chain is exactly the
same thing what happens here
okay so the physics interpretation is
that at the boundary
that's the nucleation process you start
the decoding
okay it's just the same thing as how
crystal grows for example you need first
a small
seed in which you get started once you
get started and the seed is
sufficiently larger sufficiently large
thing at the boundary
this process will simply go on and will
bring the metastable state to the stable
state
and for us that's good because for us
this means decoding
okay so with this you can construct some
very good codes
for example for rate half the capacity
should be half
just by making the degrees a little bit
larger you can see that uniformly
universally across
all the channels you can get extremely
close to capacity which would in this
case
be half by just picking codes with this
particular structure
and you can prove that you achieve the
capacity up to some small exponential
term
where the exponential term is simply in
the degrees that you have to pick
okay so um now what
application like this again these are
fairly new codes about
2010. you know people think about
in optical communication i think that
would be a very good
application so if you think of the
backbone of the internet there are
several companies that
uh they're trying to see if they could
use these type of codes
uh for optical communication okay so let
me wrap up
um what were the key ideas here a little
help at the boundary
gets things started that's the
nucleation process and then the proper
structure ensures that this
thing continues that's the
crystallization process it's a universal
phenomena that again you can use for
a wide variety of applications not just
for coding
compressive sensing for example would be
another thing that things
that would benefit so what's the next
big challenge
well probably the next big challenge
would be uh to look
at what's called the finite length
performance we know i've shown you now
like you know three four different
coding schemes that all get you to
capacity if the codes are long enough
but what's not so easy is to construct
codes that are relatively short and
they're close okay so these are the
curves this would be somewhere the
threshold what is if i have only a
length a thousand to spare you know
it's not so easy to come up with schemes
on coding schemes that for
short lengths get you very close to
capacity okay and so the question is you
know where
uh so so the way this approach these
codes this is uh given by what's called
a scaling exponent that tells you how
fast in the length
things would approach and so the scaling
exponent can be very different for
various codes the optimum is two which
would mean that the gap
to capacity that you see scales like 1
over
the square root of the block length but
many of these coding schemes that i
told you do not behave as good okay so
optimum
the gap would be just one over this
sorry the block length needed to get a
gap of delta would be one over delta
squared
but polar chords are almost the the
length is knee is almost the square of
that it's about one over
uh delta fourth this spatial couple is
one over delta third
uh ldbc is one over delta squared but
they don't actually scale to the
capacity but to another threshold okay
so
what we really would need still is codes
that are good for short
lengths where we should get some
inspiration from while you know people
used algebra they use number fear
probability
i don't know what's what's next perhaps
biology okay
there's already things spinal codes okay
quantum
okay i have no idea okay maybe we used
physics perhaps you should metaphysics
okay
so there must be a code somewhere in
there okay but perhaps you know said but
not true perhaps the best inspiration
should be the past
okay for example some of the codes that
might actually be the best is called red
miller codes
they're very close to polar codes it's
just that we neither know
you know how to decode them efficiently
and we actually can't really prove that
they're very good
but they might actually be you know
fantastic codes to use in practice if we
just knew how to
process them uh final two slides these
are
courtesy of then costello uh i've only
talked about you know this is
over the years how people came up with
schemes every point
is you know the life of a researcher or
engineer in the field okay
and so you can see that you know only
touched upon some of these schemes in
here
um and there are many many more and
that's even just a point to point when i
haven't talked about rateless codes uh
i haven't talked about network coding i
haven't talked about uh
you know many other you know interesting
developments um
and uh also dan had a nice you know set
of slides of some people involved again
this was i think 2008
there are many faces you know might be
missing and he i think he didn't even
put his own picture in there
but what i like about coding is that i
think it's a very diverse field you know
has
toronto inspirations from many many
different areas
and i think there's all reason to
believe that this will continue like
that
and so that's why i enjoy working in
this area thank you very much
we have time for a couple of questions
everything is clear
so this had to do which i you know
skipped over is
is that um you have two parameters now
the block length is
is con you know it's composed of how
many bits you have per position and then
how many positions you have in the
coupling length
and so there are two reasons why you
bounded away from capacity one is
the actual scaling of of codes when
you're close
uh you know for a certain length l so
that has simply to do with how many
points you have you have to have
sufficiently many points per position
and there's some fundamental bounds that
say if you don't you're bounded away
but the other thing is that if the
length you have the length and so
one thing i didn't mention is that at
the boundary you're losing some bits
because you have to get the process
started that's the nucleation
and so if you don't make this length
large enough then you will also be
rebounded away and so if you if you
balance what is the best thing you get
one over delta third
okay
further questions let's thank the
speaker again
thank you